Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call and a number of questions come in. But if you have any questions, make sure you chat them in.
Okay, let's jump to the questions. First question on September 19. I did both a CEA, antigen test.
And the score went up from 18.2 in August to 39. Blood draw that same day for the signature, a signature circulating tumor DNA test went down from 24 to 19.
Any suggestions on why the CEA would go up when the CT circulating tumor DNA went down.
My suggestion would be, okay, you're dealing with two completely different markers. Well, elevation of these markers would indicate could at least give you clues that the cancer is growing.
Again, the perfect example while you don't look at just one marker, you got to look at multiple markers. The CEA test is a tumor marker test. But remember that is a protein that can be elevated even when people don't have cancer.
So a person could not have cancer whatsoever, it had to have an elevated tumor marker test. And still don't know the data post surgery, you know, how long a tumor marker can be elevated to surgery.
The circulated tumor DNA test that could be argued that that might be more accurate to whether the cancer is getting, you know, the trend of that would be arguable whether the cancer is growing or diminishing size.
You know, it's just again, you just have to keep measuring everything you possibly can measure that try to draw as much data from these things as possible.
That's why just none of these tests are perfect.
And you just, you have to weigh it out between labs, between, you know, CTs, MRIs, PET scans and subjective findings. That's really the only thing you could do.
May I add a comment? So today I met with the block cancer place in Chicago with oncologist, and I asked that same question to her. And she said, you know, she's not even worried about that because she says it's inflammation marker. She says there's plenty of people walking on the streets with way higher CEAs and they don't have any sign of cancer whatsoever.
So she was more concerned with the CT DNA than anything for what that's worth. I just offer that, which is what you sort of just said too. So, yeah.
And it's just, you know, I've had people do a blood test and maybe they don't even have cancer and a marker was just way out of balance.
And then I just said you see to redo it again. And they redid the blood test and it was back with the normal. You could argue was that a lab abnormality was it something just going on in their body at that time.
Remember, this is just a draw. So many millimeters of blood out of your out of your vein and and then men taking the measurements of everything in that small little sample at that given time.
So that it just shows you that there's, you know, that while there's a value in doing labs, you can't put all the stock in there. So we got to just weigh it with other things. So, yeah, maybe there was a little bit better and more piece of answer by your columnist.
What is your opinion of hydrogen water to improve kidney function? Is there a particular brand of hydrogen generating bottle that you recommend?
Hydrogen water has been touted for a lot of things health wise, but at first came out. Oh gosh.
Maybe eight years ago or so. I remember going to a seminar on, there was an A4M seminar about all sorts of things health wise.
And of course, when the technology comes out to actually produce something, you know, there's going to be lots of anecdotal data that comes out, say, tell me an official is now you think it hydrogen water tablets to put in your water.
That could increase the hydrogenation of the water and drink the water. You could get bottles.
That will do the same thing by a specific bottle that has an apparatus to it that will increase the hydrogen concentration of your water. You could get.
A little apparatus is that set up in your kitchen or, you know, in a bathroom or something where that's where you're going to get your drinking water, typically it's set up in the kitchen.
Those last a lot longer. They're much more expensive several thousand dollars for those units.
To me, the jury's still out on the overall benefit of these things.
And they're partly I have to acknowledge the jury in my opinion on the overall benefit of these things is just because I don't have an adequate sampling of data from people.
So, you know, I just had very few patients use hydrogen water. I've had some, you know, some people say that they've been drinking hydrogen water.
But, you know, that's not the only thing they're doing. So, it's very difficult to say, you know, what's this success rate of using hydrogen water for kidney function or for cancer, you know, because it's certainly never the only thing the person is doing.
So, how much can you attribute to the hydrogen water use?
And then again, just for from my data set, we just have so few people that are using it. I just have don't really know information about it.
When it first came out, a lot of the information, a lot of the data on it makes a lot of sense that it could be beneficial.
The struggle that we had implemented it was just another state for people to do. And at that time, they were more expensive than they are now to do it.
And so, it was just something that people just were, it just was doubt reasonable.
I know the units are still pretty expensive. So, I mean, for like the culture top unit is still a couple of thousand dollars. I think the echo brand is
CCHO is a very reputable company. It's one of the first companies in this space.
I know Dr. Kelly Holderman, some of you that listen to this may recognize her name. She used to work for me years ago.
I think she's representing a company. She's their medical rep or something.
And it's out of Florida. I need to look that up again. And I could post it up on the member site.
And I think that is a bottle that you buy. And it's only a couple hundred dollars or something like that in the last 300 servings or something like that.
Or remember, I'll have to look that up. She wanted us to sell it on the store, but it was, it was kind of expensive. And we had to purchase a lot of them in order to do it.
It just didn't make sense. So, I just said I agree for people because we just don't have many people asked about hydrogen water.
So, you know, she's still a good friend of mine. And I talked to her about as often as I used to.
But I will reach out to her and get that information. I can post that up on the member site.
I wish I had more information on that. I'm sorry. I don't. I have a very strong, bold or mildly smell in my master bathroom.
There's no seal between the large shower pad and the floor and the water will occasionally get under.
There if the shower curtain isn't closed well, I'm assuming that this is the source of the smell.
Additionally, last year we had a literal flag of ants that conjugated out there, year and under the shower pad.
So, I'm assuming that there was a water source.
Now that there is this distinctive fairly overwhelming smell of mold and mildew.
A contact of the land, about a mold test. You know, anything about contributing these results.
This four cult came back over 3,000, 4th per cubic meter. They said right in the report that they like to see four counts around 1,000 or less I assume for interiors.
They listed the average for Illinois at 1,300. They yet they said they recommend no further action and puzzled by this.
It have you asked for some, and have asked for some explanation of the company, but do you have any personal experience with these tests?
Oh, at the sport levels maybe. You can send me the test. I don't know. Did you order it through immutual lyrics and we always recommend immutual lyrics labs.
I think they seem to be the more reputable. I'm not sure what lab you read the same.
I'm afraid my landlord will do nothing on the recommendation and I simply cannot live with the smell, especially knowing what it may be doing to replicate my health.
If the landlord won't pursue I am not sure what I could do on my own.
So, I would say you have to take action quite quickly on something like this.
I'm concerned with mold. If you can smell mold, you know, there's mold there. So there's no doubt about the fact that spores exist.
The problem with black mold like this is that is the is the microtoxins. So we spoke a lot about microtoxins on the zoom calls.
The toxins are the toxins that mold spores give off and then we can breathe those in. We smell mold. We can be absorbing microtoxins through our lungs.
And that is the deadly stuff. So a person can develop a sensitivity to mold and basically you can develop IGE antibodies to mold.
And then you'll have an allergic reaction when you smell mold. There's people like that. You might know somebody that, you know, they can't go into a moldy building. They'll smell mold.
Even when you can't smell mold. And they'll say, oh my gosh, I can't smell this. And you think like they're crazy or something. I don't even smell anything. What's the matter? I can't even come in here. I can't even go with here.
And people typically have IGE antibodies to mold and they react quite severely to even the smell of mold. That's not deadly, per se.
It could be very, you know, I suppose if they stayed in the room, it could be deadly because they could have some side of quite storm. However, what's deadly is the microtoxins.
And that can be picked up and seriously, people don't know that they haven't.
A microtoxin test is a urine test to test whether you have these toxins from mold.
You can use them from black mold in a building like this. You can get them from mold that could grow in food sources coffee nuts, peanut butter, things like that.
All sorts of different food sources.
You can use a dried corn, typically not corn or a common dried corn that you make cornmeal out of corn flour.
You know, all sorts of different things can have mold in them and then molds produce these toxins. And then we consume them either dietarily or breathing them in.
And those are so they can literally be deadly because they can there are citizens that they can cause all sorts of problems.
And even if they don't cause cancer, they are a major source of neural inflammation so they can cause all sorts of inflammation, microglial primate.
In the worst case, antibodies to neural tissue. So it's something you don't want to not do something about.
What can you do about this? You don't own the property.
You can't tear the tum out and tear the shower out. I don't know.
Can you seal this with cocky? Can you seal it with spray foam? Can, you know, can you, you know, make more threats to the landlord?
The problem is lots of times landlords still won't do anything or they'll do something that is highly inadequate just to pass up by the renter.
So sometimes you just got to take things in your own hands and do something.
Sealing it up so that you don't smell it would be the first thing to do.
Again, I don't know what lab you did to run these tests, but certainly you can send me the form and I can look at it.
But it's, they can be very dangerous so would not to do nothing.
Certainly, if you were able to seal that crack so that the mold that may be growing underneath there, at least you're not breathing that in.
Maybe it's going to go into the crawl space. I don't know what your, how your house was built.
But, you know, you got to, you got to take care of this because this could be very bad.
You never want exposure to mold, you never want to increase your exposure to Michael, the possible exposure to Michael toxins because they can, it can be very serious.
I have to, I have a big plague of rashes that begin in both legs on the outside of my calves and that I developed a cluster of bumps on both arms and the neck.
I was tested for Varicelo's austral virus that came up negative. I did a virtual visit with Park Nicolet, which is a clinic in Minneapolis and was prescribed cream, which is going to be a steroid like cream.
This will not treat the cause of what do I recommend.
Well, you've got to figure out what's going on here. So typically when you have a rash, you start thinking of, can it be a contact dermatitis.
So contact dermatitis is something that you might be exposed to that your skin is reacting to.
So common contact dermatitis is that you develop the sensitivity to your detergent or something and where your clothes are rubbing, then you're developing this rash.
That's quite common. People will go, we use, use tied for 40 years and we've never had this. So you can develop this sensitivity due to increase stress in your life due to, you know, just change your, your body changes metabolically from all sorts of different things.
I remember I developed a rash when I was in school in college during, I was right after my first term, finals, it was super, super stressful.
And after I was done, I developed a rash all literally all of my body and I lasted for most of the initial first term break, which was miserable.
But it was because of that giant change of stress, you had this huge cortisol release all sorts of things to change your metabolic activity, your body that you could become hypersensitive to something that you were never sensitive to be to be for.
So that would be kind of the idea of a contact dermatitis, you could also have a rash due to another source of inflammation in your body. So most common day of that would be like a food sensitivity or something like that.
Certainly, toxin, you could develop a rash, some people have had rashes from detoxing and but I don't that this would be that I've had, I've treated people over the years that have had rashes on different parts of their body that were horrific and we tested them.
It was age right when we started to treat the age of lower with burberry and garlic and and things that you treat age by Laura and went away right away.
I've had people with rashes from parasites and I don't think the parasites in themselves cause the rashes with the parasites caused this inflammatory reaction that got which then caused, you know, just to increase in systemic inflammation.
So there's lots of different reasons why a person could get a rash. Certainly, different viruses can cause rashes, different fungus can cause rashes, all sorts of different things can cause rashes.
So you want to try to get to the bottom of that. So I would suggest setting up a call with me and hopefully we can kind of dig into it a little bit.
What do you think of adding epsom salt to the foot bath water in addition to regular salt as a way to get magnesium supplementation?
Well, epsom salt is magnesium salts but I even when you take an epsom salt bath I don't know that you're really absorbing a lot of magnesium.
So magnesium as a salt is typically going to, you know, it can attach to your skin lots of people don't like epsom salt baths cause they feel itchy afterwards.
And then I suggest maybe just showering afterwards and washing that salt off because you really aren't going to absorb a salt and your skin very well.
You know, otherwise, you know, if everybody who swims in the ocean on a daily basis would have elevated sodium levels.
Well, you don't because you really don't absorb that salt through your skin.
So I don't think that using an epsom salt in your foot bath is really going to do a grand job of getting you elevated magnesium levels in your body.
Your best job take you to magnesium supplement.
So, but epsom salts can be relaxing epsom salts because it's a salt can draw toxins out of your body.
So, and it's just because it's a thionic so it could draw the other anions out.
It's going to be a canion.
And so, but I don't know that epsom salts added in a foot bath are recommended.
You could try it. I don't, if you're going to try it, I think I would replace the salt. I don't, I think we've had this question before, but I can't remember the answers that maybe nobody gave me an answer if they did try it.
So, I don't know the results. If you're going to do it, I think I would substitute the epsom salt for the regular salt, or you're going to have too much salt.
I'm having the, I haven't been following your suggested protocol and nail fungus and reviewing it yesterday.
I realized I was only taking one pill and some three of your folgical clear daily.
I've been very inconsistent applying the topical mix of essential oils with the whole theopathy two to three times a day.
I've been pretty bad with hand and what soak mostly on a low carb diet. I have cut out all sugar.
But do do a low glycemic monk root that has been that has a risk of trauma in it.
There is some limited success, but not much. It's been several months now. It is a worth changing this protocol a little.
So, this person is talking about their what fungus that they had.
I know that I would change the protocol. I think I would, if you haven't really been good at following it, I would just try to hit it hard.
Again, and see if that makes any change. I know it's really hard to do something when you're supposed to do it several times a day without setting a alarm or something like that.
It's certainly hard to apply something to your feet, but it's it's probably going to be much easier.
So, you're hit this time of year to try to do what things applications to your feet that it's going to be in the winter when you have socks on.
So, I would just try to hit it hard again and see if you could knock it down a little bit before you do any changes to the protocol.
Any other questions?
Okay, we will close out for the day. Thanks for being on and we'll get this recording out as soon as possible.
All right, bye-bye.